I think you've taken Ironman on this
great epic journey through these films
but I want you to tell me if you ever
thought when you first started reading
this one that there'd be this fight with
Avengers versus Avengers No
uh well I want to say you know I had it
all mapped out in my head I just been
I've been on the whole roller coaster
you know for years and years now it's
just been great I think we were going to
do our tenth year I remembered the comic
book series Civil War F man if we could
pull that off that'd be swell but I
didn't it was never really in the the
docket of like this is a definitive
gonna happen Marvel movie so no I think
sometimes people take roles in like a
Star Trek movie and then they're sitting
in that makeup chair for three hours
every morning yeah was there a time when
you got to the set this time that you
said not the suit again or is it fun to
put it on well what I realized is there
is a safety fun and relief in numbers
because for instance I'm sure that Chris
would tell you that he's in every shot
of the movie practically now I'm on the
poster but still whenever you put the
suit on and they've improved it over
time it is always that thing but I
thought rather than do that typical
thing of really fortunate people
complaining about their circumstances
I've come to love the suit that's great
yes the right attitude to have
I look at you putting on the suit or it
goes on all over you I just wonder if
that brings the 9 or 10 year old Robert
out in you in those moments where it
just is kind of cool do you see it
through a kid's eyes I do and also you
know now there's I mean there's kids
that are visiting the set for a bunch of
different reasons so and back on and the
second Avengers age of Ultron that we
did before this my son Exton was
visiting the set and he was going
bananas for all the Hawkeye stuff and
you know he still he's kind of over it
now because he knows that dad's deeply
invested in it so it's a little bit less
you know numinous to him I just like the
Wonder is still there yeah so we know
you play great Iron Man what do you
think makes Chris Evans a great
Captain America I really couldn't
imagine anyone else in that role and
from the first outing I think also it's
probably the highest degree of
difficulty of all the superheroes in the
Marvel world to get right and so I think
there was just a certain confidence and
humility you had to have going in and
Chris has gotten more and more detached
from his own neurosis or judgment as the
years have gone by I mean initiator like
oh my god the thing with a shield and
what if and then once it was so embraced
by you know the movie going public
I think it's really it's also afforded
him the opportunity to to do a lot of
other stuff he wants with you know
directing and all that so you know he
just has a great first of all to look
good in that helmet is like I don't know
they should have done like a random like
facial pattern search you know it was
just the right guy for the job Tony
Stark does a flip-flop when he sides
with the government as an actor how did
you approach making that change seem
grounded and intrinsic got the audience
what's funny I was thinking a couple
days ago an Iron Man 2 I'm saying that
the government can't have the suit and
it's my private property and all that
stuff and now I'm saying we got a
designer deliver but I think about it I
was just relating to it as it just being
a function of age like the things you're
so determined and passionate about in
your thirties and 40s when you start
looking at the back nine you're like or
maybe I'm entirely wrong you know
because you don't it you don't really
have the time and energy to stay as
rigid you know and you say 30s and 40s
but this movie takes you back to when
you were a teenager I want that camera
in my life that we know I know
that's great special effects right but
it's kind of like it would be like some
some healthy hallucinogen wearing off
and then like I'll know the real world
again yeah I don't even want to know how
they did it there's there is this
spectacle and this grand scale of things
but there is this human conflict in the
movie
and that's what I kept writing down in
my notes that it just seems so much more
real than a lot of movies like this so
did you tell me about that human
conflict and then the conflict you have
to deal with with Steve Rogers which is
pretty emotional in this film yeah well
again I mean there's so many people to
credit there is the way Jon Favreau set
up just the first iron man movie that it
seemed like anything that's going to
hinge off this world we're going to
pretend that somehow other it could
belong in this world
and then from the first Avengers film
Joss Whedon was to his credit you know
and Marvel and Kevin and everybody were
there like alright we just want to kind
of feather this in and lightly insinuate
that there's going to be trouble down
the road and so I think you know the the
prologue to it has been really well
executed which to me is just a movie go
or somebody just loves movies and
follows things and series and gets
strung out on all this stuff you know I
just appreciate the care with which it's
been executed but then I guess to like
it sometimes you feel I have felt guilty
about the jealousy or envy I've had for
other people's relationships with the
world or just like that that childish
thing of why you know and because Tony's
dad Howard
so felt that Steve Rogers was the
definitive American he was like a son to
him and then there's always as usual all
this kind of dark tragedy around
everything so you know it was in there
it was always in the comic books and
then I credit the Russos the directors
for really being able to again keep it
grounded and once they took over the
Captain America side of things I felt
like they were kind of pretty close to
Favreau's original ideation of how
things should be played so you mentioned
the Russos and I think would be
difficult enough to work with one
director but you've got two Minds
working do they always work in sync do
you love it what's the difference well
first of all you know usually I mean
there's no good cop bad cop
both really flexible in the way they
work so but then there'd be certain
things like if I was doing the HUD work
well I'm like sitting with a camera five
inches away from my face and it's really
just odd and uncomfortable um usually
Anthony would be the person deal with
that because there's something just a
little bit more receptive about him but
um but Joe would have done great too and
I just I just loved watching a team work
together
sounds like you're saying two heads are
better than one here yeah I married I
got me thinking every film should have
at least two directors because you can't
get mad at everybody all at the same
time yeah well I mean look there's times
and parts of it where I'm sure like in
the arc of doing a character on a on a
long-running series or whatever you know
the mind can start going you know oh
what else is that or whatever but it's
just been such a great great experience
for me and I'm super grateful there are
New Avengers who joined teamironman were
they predictable choices or were there
surprises in that selection um I
wouldn't say any of them are predictable
per se but I mean to me again going back
to the the second Iron Man which me
seems like ages ago agent Romanoff
now obviously Black Widow you know and
it always seemed like just everybody
wanted her to not like me or me to not
trust her you know so I thought it was
really smart and again you know the
thing Marvel does so well is if you're
going to have an expectation or start
divvying up who you think will be on
what side there's always a couple of
surprises so so we have Black Panther in
the movie now what do you think of that
introduction and what do you think
chadwick boseman brought through the
role I without taking away from anything
else I think it's the most exciting
thing that's happened in the history of
the universe because there was enough
space and enough success to go and say
well really how
how do you explain the marvel universe
in its entirety and how how its evolved
over time and so just coming from such a
technologically advanced country and
being someone who very much has his own
agenda
and then there's just Chadwick himself
who to me is such a dynamic just guy and
obviously a great actor but I think it
super inspired piece of casting and then
yeah and then knowing that mr. Kugler is
directing him in the Black Panther movie
to me it was like man that just that
might just take the cake right there
yeah I didn't use a terrific actor I
agree with you okay there's an epic
battle scene between these two teams and
there's emotional responses as you're
doing it because you kind of like each
other I guess um how did you feel when
you squared off against team cap well
part of it is I hate to say it it's a
very Western thing you know when you're
on a team you're on a team kind of like
a platoon and automatically if you're
looking over the the trenches at
anything else you tend to get in that
kind of competitive spirit we spent all
spent a fair amount of time together I
actually feel like I got to know teamcap
better just because I was able to
observe them more because I wouldn't be
shooting oftentimes when they were so
regardless of how we were playing it I
was just looking at I mean now you look
on this poster and there's you know
there's ten individuals on it and I'm
like wow you know I'm just I'm just glad
I'm you know still relevant what can
fans expect when they see Captain
America Civil War they can expect the
unexpected but they will have that that
trademark Marvel Entertainment and
sophistication and storytelling and and
just really strong performances a most
fun thing of the entire shooting
experience for you and it may have been
just on your day off but your oh there's
one sequence where without giving too
much away there's a threat and we have
to try to contain it and and things have
gotten to the point where there's so
many suits and here
rose and everything that we were
thinking what if he just has a watch
that kind of turns into a weapon for a
second so there's still always this
innovation that occurs so we basically
literally had in this one sequence Tony
just basically has a watch that kind of
turns into a like a one-shot derringer
and so it's gone from the point where
like you know a 20 minute sequence used
to get me excited now one little frame
and you know that it's a great moment
though and the last question I have for
you really is that the audience's are
rooting for everyone they are so
invested whenever I go to one of these
movies I'm stunned they're unlike any
other audience have you figured out what
that is and have you ever sat in the
back of a theater to just enjoy that
response I have and I suspect I will
with this too but it's just like again
you know like um you know jungle books
going to be out in a minute and other my
friends do movies and I think there's
this um there's just kind of a
fraternity of people who don't pooh-pooh
this kind of genre movie and I met a
fair amount of them the first time I
went to comic-con and and I am friendly
with people who kind of you know peek
out of the closet you go dude him crazy
about civil war whatever so I think
again that you know because the movies
are just executed very well they they
exist as just pure entertainment but
then there's this little constellation
that gets lit up in people who are fans
of the comics back in the day or just
love this kind of storytelling so um you
know I'm all for geeking out on Marvel
pix Paul your character vision
introduced in the Avengers age of Ultron
it's a new part of the team what were
some of the fun parts of bringing the
guided this world this time really
really excited about where the vision is
going in the future and I think what
they've done has begun to sort of
broaden him you know in an age of Ultron
you see this omnipotent creature born
and he's both
omnipotent and yet and very naive and by
the time we get to this movie I think
he's trying to figure out what it means
to be human and how he can best protect
humanity and you know he's a logical
creature and and logic doesn't have just
doesn't you know it doesn't a guarantee
loyalty whereas love guarantees loyalty
so I think he's trying to figure that
out and I think that's going to be very
important for Humanity moving forward in
this universe Chadwicks so we see the
black panther now here it's this
character fans have been waiting to see
here so what traits and what elements do
you think you brought to evoke in your
portrayal of this character um I you
know I feel like there is a he's a
strategist I think there is a
gamesmanship there is a you know a
hopefully of a broto that you that you
get from him and a sense of
responsibility a connection to his to
his culture and past his ancestors and I
think there is an elusiveness to him not
just his character but also physically I
think hopefully all those things come
come through he has to to uh to have to
serve the dual purpose of being a
warrior and also a monarch so finding a
place where you can you know a central
place where you can go from one to the
other I think is also important so I
think those are some of the things we
live for and tried to do and find and if
we if the moments are not organic
however then you have to play to the
next one so but I like the way that we
see a definite change as the movie goes
but also with you when you were reading
this script for the first time not
knowing what this guy was going to be
evolving into were you surprised and
then saying oh yes well there I am again
this is good yeah I mean you know uh-huh
the scripts are that I have to read
these scripts when they come in I have
to read them about three times to work
out what the hell is going on because
they so that they're so huge and there's
so much action and so hard to follow on
the page and then yeah I think it's
really for the vision it's a really
logical place to move his character
forward and that you know the little I
know of where where the vision is moving
toward I think this is um it it really
it really makes sense as a sort of
linking piece for him so so I'm guessing
you've been asked this question about 20
times today but I want you to explain
for us what you felt when you put that
costume on for the very first time and
your favorite part of the design my
favorite part is the the necklace it's
hard it's hard actually it's the
necklace but I also love the shoes I
love the shoes I love the hotter shoes
fill of the boots fill there's a web
their web toes and even though you're in
boots you feel like you're walking on
the ground so it I think that helps with
the sort of the animal type feeling you
feel like you have paws and claws and
all of that uh the it feels um I think
there's a lot of different feelings that
come across like you feel a certain
amount of power and
you feel like the deception of the
there's a lot of deception and power I
think with the COS time you get to go to
Germany and you're filming does that
inform the way you do your performance
because you're there in this great big
place or would you rather just be on the
soundstage uh yeah I mean I one of the
great things about this film aside one
of the great things about having a
career in in in movies is is travel I
love it and I think that more people
travel the more you would see that yes
there are obviously lots of differences
between us over there are many more
similarities and so I think it is so
it's a real it's one of the great it's
one of the great blessings of this job
is being able to go and stay and not
stay not stay like a tourist you know
you you know I remember being I was in
Mexico I shot a film in Mexico as there
for six months and and you you you you
really you know you start to have a
rhythm and a life in that in that
country so travel in general and and
gotten going at different places I up
into Germany a lot but it and it's it's
a it's an extraordinary country one
minute left to go on this round before
the next interview chair look when you
first step down to the tarmac to do this
epic battle sequence tell me what the
emotional response was to this what
would be this great moment in the film
my god it's 110 degrees responses we're
gonna do it out here like
we're serving 30 but but but but other
than that yeah you you look around and
you see the kid part of you is looking
at that the superheroes that you're one
of and that you're going to play off of
and there's a posturing um you know
there because of that and then the the
actor the artist is looking at the
actors who are playing them and that's
you know just as exhilarating if not
more exhilarating and then you had again
after that
you